-Our next guest is
a very funny stand-up comedian
whose book "Misfit: Growing Up
Awkward in the '80s,"
is available now,
and his latest special,
"Born on Third Base,"
premieres on Max December 21st.
Let's take a look.
-I don't mean to
distance myself from you,
but I fly Comfort Plus.
[ Laughter ]
It's just -- it's a trade-off.
For an extra $135, usually,
I can get the leg room
that prevents me
from having my legs amputated
because of blood clots.
I cannot sit
in the coach class.
It just doesn't work for me.
So I'm going to
my Comfort Plus seat.
I get so anxious
and embittered.
I always say, "Honey, don't be
impressed with these people.
If they had
their [bleep] together,
they'd be in a private jet
right now."
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Gary Gulman!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-Oh. It's so --
I'm so excited to be back.
Thank you for having me on.
-I am -- always so lovely
to talk to you.
You always seem to be
in the best mood.
And what I've appreciated,
though, is you have been so open
and honest about
mental-health issues, recovery.
You did a great special
called "The Great Depresh."
Have you -- have you
enjoyed the feedback from people
who appreciate how much you talk
about those issues?
-Oh, my word.
It came out four years ago,
and yet I get e-mails every day
from somebody who it helped,
and they always thank me.
And I'm like, "No,
you did all the hard work.
I just made a special that made
you feel better for an hour."
So I'm just so grateful.
I felt obligated, after I felt
better, to share this story
and give some people hope.
So I'm so grateful
at how it's turned out.
-And now "Misfit."
-Yes.
-This is a book.
How did you come up
with the title for "Misfit"
about your growing-up years?
-Well, I'm a big Rush fan.
-Okay.
-And so they had this song
that brought me great comfort
in the '80s,
in my adolescence,
was called "Subdivisions."
And there was a line in there
where they said --
It's about the suburbs.
It says, "Nowhere else
is the dreamer
or the misfit so alone."
And so I wanted --
when I decided to write a book,
I said, "I want
to make these misfits,
these people
who felt uncomfortable
in high school and older --
and we still don't fit in
as adults sometimes --
that they would feel
a little bit better about that.
So I don't sing
or play the drums,
but I can write funny,
funny stories, so...
-I'm so impressed
with your recall
of the things you experienced
at that young age.
Did it all come
flooding back to you,
like, your time in the '80s,
or did you have to,
like, dig to find them?
-No, it didn't have
to flood back
because these were stories
that had haunted me
since they happened
in a lot of cases.
Or, I've told this --
-The tight focus of trauma.
Yeah.
-You never forget being
in first grade, and it's the --
it was in September.
And I said
to my first grade teacher,
who was also
my next-door neighbor,
which was a thing back then,
you would just live
right next door.
And so it was Mrs. Burns,
and I said,
"Who am I going to have
for second grade, Mrs. Burns?"
And she said, "Your father
hasn't told you?"
And I was repeating
the first grade.
Even though I was in Sun Up,
which was the top reading group,
it was the top reading group,
and the Sun Up kids
read gorgeous, beautifully.
No fingers
or anything like that.
[ Laughter ]
And then I found out --
So you never forget that.
-This is not your first book.
I was very impressed.
You wrote this when you were
in second grade?
-Yeah. This was my first book.
-"The Lonely Tree."
The working --
-Now, I will say, I've got
a second grader right now,
and I saw this,
I'm like, "Oh, my God.
This is so much better than what
my son could do."
-[ Laughing ] Really?
-So now I'm happy to know
you did first grade twice.
-Yes. Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
-I know he's got
a full nother year.
-That's so good.
Yeah.
-So, "The Lonely Tree."
-I should've been in third.
-Yeah. This is --
But this is very well done.
-Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
The working title
was "A Cry for Help."
-"A Cry for Help," yeah.
-Yes.
-When you have a kid
who writes a book called
"The Lonely Tree"...
[ Laughter ]
...they're like,
"Let's red-flag this one."
But it's really beautiful.
-Oh, thank you.
-And look at this.
Like, I like that it's --
we're gonna get all love --
love, Gary, to your readers.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughing ]
-Well, in those days,
I didn't have a lot of income,
so I would give gifts
I made from school.
And that was a present
to my mom and dad,
who didn't even live
in the same home.
So my mom wound up keeping it,
but my dad brought it around
and tried to get it published,
which is insane.
-Aww, that's very sweet.
-It is very sweet.
-That's very sweet.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Did you -- speaking of,
you grew up with
not a lot of money, and
you actually talked about that
in "Born on Third Base."
-Yes.
-And you talk about
income inequality,
and it's something
you're still noticing.
-Yeah. It wasn't
as bad when we grew up.
Now, and even in our industry,
for instance,
do you remember the guy
who played Jerry on "Seinfeld"?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
He is worth $1 billion.
-What?
-Yeah, $1 billion.
He has a building in Manhattan
where he houses an extensive
Porsche collection.
And I just --
I hate to compare, but...
[ Laughter ]
...my wife and I,
we don't have enough room
on our kitchen counter
to keep the toaster
on display at all times.
[ Laughter ]
We have to keep it --
I said, "Let's keep it
in a cabinet,"
and then she said,
"You mean the cabinet?"
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And then when you have
guests over and you're like,
"Do you want toast?"
and it's like this thing.
-The beauty of this audience is,
you're all picturing
a four-slicer.
[ Laughter ]
It's -- It's the deuce.
-Yeah.
Oh, it's only two slices?
-Yes!
-You don't even have room
on a counter
for the double-slicer.
-No, because we have to keep
the coffee maker.
-Well, of course.
-Because that's the only thing
that makes life tolerable.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But you were obviously --
All jokes aside,
you're doing very well.
You're a very successful
comedian.
-Oh, thank you.
-And you have
recently upgraded your wardrobe.
-Oh, yes.
Um, I don't want you
to feel sorry for me
about the countertop,
because this is
all Banana Republic.
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, I'm in the --
I'm in the
Banana Republic tax bracket.
Now, full disclosure,
I purchased this
during one of Banana Republic's
thrice weekly 40% off sales.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-If you put any effort in,
you can wear this ensemble
for the price of Old Navy.
You just --
[ Laughter ]
You do -- You wait
for the 40% off sale,
which is, like, now, and then...
[ Laughter ]
...and then you go online,
you get the 20% off promo code,
and I'll give you my code.
It's "Winter savings."
[ Laughter ]
"Winter savings."
-Are you allowed --
Are they cool with you
just giving that to everyone?
-But here's the twist.
I always think to myself,
"Oh, I could've guessed that,"
when I get the promo code.
But the truth is,
I couldn't have guessed it.
There's so --
It's just a little...
The "savings" is spelled
with a dollar sign.
-Ah.
-Oh. Banana...
-That's how they tell the
riffraff from the insiders.
-$30 for the cardigan.
How much for the whimsy?
[ Laughter ]
Free whimsy at Banana Republic,
while supplies last.
-Yeah.
Now I have one --
I know you have loved comedy
from a young age.
-Oh, yeah.
-But from a young age,
there was a piece of comedy...
-[ Laughs ]
-...that you did not care for,
which is crowd work.
-Yes.
-Okay. What was it about
crowd work that you didn't like?
-Well, in high school,
we would go
to Nick's Comedy Stop in Boston.
-Yes.
-And I wanted to hear the jokes
and then tell them to kids
in school on Monday.
-Totally understand.
-And you can't do that if it's,
"Hey, what do you do for work?"
-Right.
-And I just remember thinking,
"All right, if anybody asks me
what I did for work..."
To this day, if I was
at a comedy show, incognito...
[ Laughs ]
...and they said,
"What do you do for work?"
I would stand up and say,
[ Laughter ]
"I -- I didn't come here
to be forcibly cast
in your TikTok video."
[ Laughter ]
"I want to tell these jokes
at school on Monday."
[ Laughter ]
-You would still do that today.
-[ Laughs ]
-And you don't think that last
part would be weird to them?
-That would be very odd, yes.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-They're like, what?
How many times
have you been held back?
[ Laughter ]
This book is so wonderful.
-Oh, thank you.
-It really is a beautiful --
-And you wrote the blurb
on the back.
-I blurbed it.
I like to blurb it.
-Yeah.
-Look, it was
an honor to blurb your work.
-It's an honor to have
your name on there,
because I've admired you
from the get-go.
Meaning from "Jump Street."
-Oh, wow.
Those are --
Yeah. I think almost
everybody uses those the same.
-Best lyrics.
[ Both laugh ]
-It's such a pleasure
to see you.
Guys, this is
the great Gary Gulman.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Born on Third Base" premieres
on Max December 21st.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."